n'est pas à l'abri les visiteurs qui
viendront solliciter les établissements
parce qu'ils ont été contaminés à
l'occasion d'une visite
on va voir tout un tas de procédure
d'une part des patients qui sont
négatifs à l'encré hôpital et comme on
leur fait justement à une pcr a
rencontré à l'hôpital avant de les
opérer la plupart des établissements
santé aujourd'hui pour vous faire opérer
on vous demande un test qui doit être
négatif
et si on les contaminés par le virus
durant l'hospitalisation d'un événement
car ce week end comme ça arrive un peu
partout les visiteurs qui seraient
contaminés il peut y avoir ce sera une
infection nosocomiale est ce qu'ils
n'ont pas été pris en charge
médicalement
mais on verra sans doute été le
conseiller donc il faut peser le pour et
le contre il ya toujours un équilibre à
trouver toujours donc d'un premier point
de vue ses appareils intéressant et moi
je pense qu'il faudrait différencier
vraiment les étals et également les
établissements pour personnes
handicapées comme c'est prévu dans une
des propositions de loi donc dans les
écoles et les établissements qui sont
des lieux de vie pour personnes
handicapées c'est effectivement leur
domicile et il ya sans doute eu des abus
dans le cadre de la restriction des
droits ou comme l'avait d'ailleurs la
défenseure des droits dans son rapport
au billet vert et donc on a interdit les
personnes effectivement le devoir leur
famille donc là c'est leur lieu de vie
c'est leur domicile et peut-être font
que une loi pourrait être utile pour
effectivement on laisse un petit peu
moins de l'altitude
même s'il faut toujours laisser dans
l'axé cube aux directeurs des
établissements pour voir au cas par cas
mais peuvent être instaurés
effectivement un droit de visite dans
ces établissements
par contre il ya donc dans une
proposition de loi et les proposer de
l'étendre ces établissements de santé et
là je pense qu'il y aura beaucoup de
difficultés si on a un droit de visite
pour les familles dans les états de
soins de santé sans aucun l'âme le fou
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
demain ils famille va venir nous dire
notre cotisation de 5 ans il veut voir
son grand père et son père qui est en
réanimation il ya aucune raison de lui
interdire
donc parce que dans les propositions de
loi il n'est pas non plus prévu que ce
soit pour les personnes majeures
donc ça veut dire que les enfants
mineurs pourrait venir à l'hôpital voir
y compris en réanimation des personnes à
scorer un droit de visite
ça veut dire générer du contentieux
parce que c'est écrit dans la loi on ya
droit et on nous a empêché de voir la
personne parce qu'on est venu la loi et
nous avons le matin ce n'est pas
possible
et puis on est venu mais le patient
était parti faire des examens
donc du coup sa part il est possible et
on aura des revendications de qui seront
parfois difficile à gérer pour les
équipes que j'ai le droit c'est écrit
dans la loi je le peux venir me voir
tous les jours alors qu'on sait très
bien que les données d'hospitalisation
les durée moyenne de séjour sont très
courtes maintenant par rapport à avant
les gens restent très peu de temps à
l'hôpital
la chirurgie ambulatoire et c'est donc
instaurer un droit de visite journalier
à l'hôpital et en clinique pour tous les
patients il compte
et alors y compris mais aussi pour les
patients mineurs du coup et là ça ne
m'interpelle par exemple on sait qu'il
ya des mineurs qui sont spécialisés dans
le plâtre d'anorexie mentale ou via un
contrat qui était établie entre les
psychiatres et les parents avec eux
at-elle à échéance pour le rallye et des
coups de fil idées
visite et c'est donc ça complique si
vraiment la prise en charge donc
notamment pour ces mineurs mais
également les établissements publics de
santé mentale et tous les établissements
où on prend en charge des patients pour
des soins psychiatriques où ça pourrait
être complexe donc d'instaurer ce droit
de visite
donc s'ils s'étaient étendus aux
établissements ça entraînerait de
grandes difficultés
et puis on a besoin que c'est pratique
ça veut dire mettre en place des
procédures on l'a déjà vu avec le la
contention c'est très compliqué la
contention tout un tas de procédures de
vérification où la famille va demander à
le voir on va solliciter les soignants
pour savoir si c'est justifié ou pas
même si fier ça veut dire des pressions
sur les médecins alors d'angine bp plc
noter côté le chef de service qui va
décider le chef de service il est pas
tous les jours il va forcément les
réponses du service donc évidemment il
ne faut pas que ce soit que le chef de
famille il est cuit ça veut dire quand
même des pressions importantes pour
ouvrir les sites
je trouve qu'il est contre indiquée à
des fins dans dans la ppl qui est la
plus longue où il ya la partie clos 1 où
il est dit qu'aucune visite ne peut être
subordonnée à une information préalable
de l'établissement bon heureusement
heureusement que les gens soient obligés
de faire une demande va là pour le coup
avec le commis de sireix issa qui a été
instauré mais on va on va pas instauré
de farine ne demande pour venir visiter
une personne hospitalisée mais en même
temps à l'article 3 de cette ppl et les
noter et lorsque les visiteurs à forme
établissement d'une visite au moins vers
un accord avant l'heure prévue
le directeur dispose de 21 ans aussi
opposés c'est un travail très très
complexe d'avoir un délire 24 heures
cinq ans c'est trop rare pour s'imposer
les visites sur quels critères on va s'y
opposer pour le directeur ça veut dire
derrière qu'on va mettre en place des
procédures qui vont être complétés
source de réservation contentieux je
vous demande à les choses difficiles
dans la plupart des tentes
tout se passe bien et les visiteurs
qu'on veut venir visiter leur famille et
qu'il ya même des cas on aimerait tous
de visiter leurs familles mais
malheureusement ils ont coupé visite
donc c'est plutôt et les soignants sont
plutôt dans la sollicitation de
rechercher des personnes qui viennent
visiter la plupart du temps ça se passe
bien banks et c'est toujours compliqué
de légiférer et de donner un cadre qui
va être plus rigide avec le contraignant
alors que le comte sens en règle
générale règle les choses là on a été
sur une épidémie avec un virus inconnu
pour protéger les patients quand une
fois on a restera ce droit de visite
il faut sans doute maintenant améliorer
les choses et donc et notamment
effectivement dans les établissements
pour personnes handicapées mais je pense
l'instaurer dans les établissements
santé tout venant ça rendrait les choses
encore plus complexe puisque avant tout
il faut quand même éviter aussi à l'envi
sur une pathologie particulière
voilà et bien maintenant manque dupont
directeur de péta les clés adjoint la
terex trice des affaires juridiques de
l'ap-hp oui mesdames et messieurs merci
de cette habitation soit mes fonctions
sont au siège de l'assistance publique
plutôt affaires juridiques et des droits
des patients et c'est vrai que pendant
cette période si particulière chacun un
peu sorti un peu de ses fonctions
habituelles et se trouve cela sert
habilement je me suis la plus chargée de
cette question des visites pour les 39
hôpitaux de l'assistance publique parce
qu'il y avait une question qui se pose
est s'est brutalement auxquelles on
n'avait jamais vraiment réfléchi
qui était celle dont des de la visite à
l'hôpital jala que je rejoins sur
beaucoup de points smi lundi le temps de
jeu je retrouve bien là des choses si ce
qui revient d'une expérience
hospitalière le quotidienne et celle
qu'on avait pu voir pendant la crise je
pense aussi qu'il ya des jeunes qui
n'ont pas le droit de visite en général
enfin ça recouvre des situations assez
différentes
le choix de l'ehpad c'est pas exactement
le service de l'animation
le service de médecine ordinaire c'est
pas forcément commencer ce de pédiatrie
willoqueaux est vraiment dans des
situations un peu différente même s'il
ya bien sûr quelques préoccupations
avoir sur cette notion de droit de
visite qui aujourd'hui n'apparaît pas
expressément finalement d'entrer dans
les textes il ya aussi une question du
ray face à caen privé de visite quelques
jours une personne adulte qui est en
rénovation c'est une chose privée
pendant des semaines et des mois des
personnes de visite c'est autre chose
donc c'est vrai qu'on est dans une
situation différente en situation de
crise
enfin comme tout avait plutôt compléter
un petit peu ce qui est de mon point de
vue je pense qu'ils aient ainsi de
choses jusqu'à présent les textes et
puis la préoccupation qu'on avait c'est
essentiellement plutôt le droit de
visiter c'est le patient qui décide ce
qu'il veut et celui qui dit qu'il veut
et qui parfois il veut pas d'ailleurs ce
qui était beaucoup exprimé pendant la
période récente c'est plutôt le droit de
visiter tous les aidant les familles les
proches qui disent c'est tout à fait
anormal c'est scandaleux je vais pas pu
voir ma mère j'ai pu voir en perd
surtout lorsqu'il était serré et
d'ailleurs la question donc on se
construit sur le droit de visite il a
ainsi couru aussi à mon avis dans ce qui
a beaucoup choqué l'opinion le
délitement avec la suite pour les jeux
lorsque le séjour a mal fini c'est à
dire que il ya un sujet qui était celui
des champs mortuaire suivi la
présentation des corps pour les
personnes qui ont sont décédées pendant
cette période
oui pendant un exemple personnel
lorsqu'on est ce qu on sait moi
m'occuper ce sujet là assez tardivement
jeu
aussitôt raconte pourquoi c'était un
témoignage d'une famille qui ne nous
dira d'ici fin mars
c'est terrible depuis quelques vignerons
mari est parti un jour parce qu'ils
étaient très malades pour le colis dont
marie l'adulte pas un personnage n'était
pas un dépanneur et le parti donc à
l'hôpital on a interdit de venir le voir
pendant toute cette période
et puis finalement on m'a dit mais il va
très mal ça va très mal mais je n'ai pas
encore tout de suite
et puis après midi banlieue à doubler
des folies pour gaza où il est décédé et
après on me dit mais le corps de votre
barbier dans une mousse europe à
l'ouvrir et donc vous pouvez pas votre
présentation des corps comment voulez
vous comme vous l'auriez souhaité et
tout ça dans un contexte qu'on a fait a
pour but aussi qui était celui de mars
avril et c'est vrai en ce moment là je
pense que c'était vraiment le plus le
plus dur nous ferons quoi c'est dans une
ville de paris qui était complètement
vide
il n'y a pas de circulation et même les
visiteurs nous est à peine d'alors lé
l'hôpital de même
ou parce que ce n'était pas forcément
évident d'être traversé paris pour aller
à l'hôpital
on a pu oublier ça et puis je pense à
cette époque là une trame très très fort
il ya un peu de vent de protection des
malades qui étaient particulièrement
importantes
faut il pouvoir distinguer le donne
sujets que vous a vendu aujourd'hui le
droit de visite
en période de crise avec celui en temps
normal on devait présenter leurs
produits rodez 12 nuls
le travail c'est la situation afin le
droit de visite pendant la période de
crise mais je pense que c'est assez
différent
l'expérience hospitalière qu'on peut
avoir c'est que le droit de visite il
est aujourd'hui absolument pas
problématique en temps ordinaire
c'est-à-dire que alignés derrière et
même plus à une augmentation pour leur
part la peine tellement c'est devenu
quelque chose de normal c'est à dire que
lorsqu'on fait un peu l'histoire
hospitalière on sera en sortant de la
période de l'humanisation des hôpitaux
dans les années 70 où elle est partie
avec des textes qui disait d'ailleurs on
avait déjà bien décrire les peuples qui
prévoyait le droit des visites
quotidiennes dans les hôpitaux
et puis le pit ont été tenus d'avoir
deux plages horaires par jour pour les à
l'accès des visiteurs aux hôpitaux
et c'est lui tellement normal que
finalement cette alimentation a disparu
au début des années 2000 aux jeux n'a
plus rien on a plus que les textes qui
au contraire viennent empêcher la visite
lorsqu'il ya les difficultés qu'a
famille des questions soit la famille et
en perturbant dedans pour le repos des
malades soient ils les prennent aux
disciplines comportements qui sont très
problématiques et non pour dire que le à
l'hôpital public enfin je pense pareil
en clinique je pense que aujourd'hui la
visite est plus fin
en temps normal y'a pas de problème ça
que je suis un temps de lire au lit
visite s'était jamais le matin tard le
soir alors qu'on va dans les hôpitaux
parisiens actuellement un rendement
actuel ce qui se passe en famille
devient le matin souvent et bien à midi
autant dire pas entendre au moment des
soins ils viennent le tard le soir le
travail donc on est vraiment venu dans
un régime assez peu changé c'est peut
être différent d'un service est en
hausse mais globalement il ya une
évolution considérable de la visite
n'ont pas le droit de visite que de la
visite de fait croquer et un nom de
visiteurs parfois important bond à la
mort il ya une très grande liberté il me
semble nous invite en temps ordinaire
c'est ce qui peut-être nous a un peu
rendu les choses plus compliquées
lorsque la crise est arrivée parce qu'on
n'avait pas tellement réfléchi à céder
tous les sujets là et je ne vais tomber
dessus et dans les premières semaines
d'ailleurs on y pense c'est pas
tellement celle que le sujet était
d'abord de protéger les malades de
protéger les personnels et donc il y
avait une forme de vol à deux c'était la
suspension de toutes les visites
immédiate parce que l'on voulait
absolument que il n'y pas de caster qui
n'est pas de dégâts dans les services
après il ya des exemples je suis j'ai un
souvenir d'un grand siège parisien dans
lequel un patient un visiteur est venu à
jour ils étaient testés d'ailleurs il
était on sait pas qu'il avait le cou
vide il ya infecté 11 personnes dans le
service par son simple pas saluer et
après on a une à signaler après le
lendemain on dira qu'il avait été testé
positif
il ne savait pas en revanche si tu es
enfin pousser un petit peu tétanisé
toute l'équipe a fait un visiteur qui
vient comme ça qui a écrit par lee a
contaminé aux personnes c'est quand même
bon
omettant que vous dire d'autre
oui à ce sujet dans tous les sens aux
choses à dire sur le sujet des visites
je dois témoigner aussi qu'il ya
certaines familles qui étaient
terrorisés par le fait que maintenir le
droit de visites dans les hôpitaux
bonjour encore un père d'un jeune adulte
ce qui nous avait fait d'être scandalisé
par cette année de ça
comment se fait-il qu'on permette encore
de visiter mon fils qui est qui et des
visites dans l'hôpital où mon fils
d'hospitaliser les risques sont
considérables vous devriez absolument
limiter les visites on aurait donc et
pourtant les limites et beaucoup à la
fois les limites et beaucoup c'est à
dire avec derek était plutôt un visiteur
par patient et par jour pas de patients
coville et c'est donc le 6 mois du temps
faille aurait beaucoup à dire que c'est
cesser c'est un sujet qui est qui et qui
a beaucoup en kirundi vous pourrez
répondre à deux questions réponses et
chacun apporte pas la question assurent
et donc que ce que je lui aussi c'est
que du point de vue du juriste donc
enrichie praticiens du droit à l'hôpital
ce qui me frappe aussi mais ça on
l'avait jamais avant la crise du comité
que tous le droit de la santé le droit
l'hôpital aujourd'hui le droit des
patients il est fondé sur le patient
autrement dit elle énormément de choses
sur les droits des malades le droit de
la personne et même lorsqu'il avoue
kouchner en 2002 c'est vrai que c'est
vrai le patient tout seul il est entouré
autant dit le droit d et dans le droit
des accompagnants il est quasiment
indigents 3 du code de la santé publique
par exemple le temps d'un autre exempt
qui passe lui de la visite mais on a
régulièrement des difficultés va ou des
litiges avec les familles pour des
personnes pro des passions qu'ils sont
inconscients ou qui sont dans le coma il
est proche
le conjoint le les enfants veulent avoir
accès au dossier médical et on leur dit
ben non moi conclut patient est vivant
il n'y a que lui qui pourrait vous
donner le droit d'accéder à son dossier
médical
evènement je conduis un exemple ce qui
veut dire l'aiguillon des litiges en la
matière mais tout pour vous dire que
même le droit ou le droit le droit du
proche l'hôpital il est on tente domaine
de la santé il est très peu consistants
et c'est vrai que hors la matière du
coup le droit de la visite le droit de
visiter son procédé lui-même très
exigeant donc est ce que je peux vous
dire pour la première intervention
alors offrez mon général du collectif
tenir ta main est à présent plus là le
côté famille et c'est votre collectif
avait été reçu par le président larcher
entre sainte
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
permettez-moi de revenir sur les raisons
de la présence ce matin qui permettront
je l'espère de mieux saisir les réalités
de ce que nous connaissons depuis plus
d'un an maintenant mon père de
médicaments avait 70 ans elle était
médecin en pleine santé encore en
activité et en octobre dernier il a
contacté locaux vides
il a été hospitalisé à la clinique axium
d'aix-en-provence est d'emblée l'équipe
médicale nous a interdit toute visite en
service de réanimation comme dans tout
établissement
les visites c'était interdit pour tout
le monde après une semaine mon père est
d un tube est sorti du coma artificiel
il passera les dix jours suivant dans la
solitude la plus totale malgré ses
demandes insistantes pour nous voir
malgré notre présence aux portes mêmes
de ce service qui nous saurons rester
désespérément closes nous n'aurons
j'étais en contact avec les médecins
réanimateurs que deux fois une première
fois à notre demande pour qu'il nous
explique de ne pas l'appeler pour ne pas
le déranger la seconde fois pour qu'ils
nous annoncent le décès de mon père le 9
novembre
mon père aura passé les dernières
semaines de sa vie dans l'isolément le
plus total sans personne pour
l'accompagner dans cette solitude
contrainte
le médecin cochera négligemment la case
mise en bière immédiate nous privant de
tout adieu à sa dépouille
mon père est donc parti dans une housse
en plastique sans plus de considération
ce n'est qu'après d'importantes
pressions extérieures que la direction
de la clinique axium finira par concéder
à ma mère le droit de pouvoir entrevoir
quelques minutes le visage de mon père
dans une pièce réfrigérée surveillé par
deux personnes
mon frère ayant été contraints de rester
à la porte ce n'est qu'après avoir
obtenu avec difficulté le dossier
médical de mon père que nous aurons nous
apprendrons la vérité mon père n'est pas
mort du comité il avait subi trotter si
négatif durant la semaine précédant son
décès il est mort d'une septicémie
contractée dans le service qui devait le
soigner l'interdiction de visite qui
nous a été opposé était donc été donc
non seulement illégal mais en plus
dénuées de fondement sanitaire
après plusieurs semaines de sidération
et de révolte j'ai réalisé que
malheureusement notre cas n'était pas
isolé et que ce recul inédit de
civilisation je pèse mes mots était
partagée par des milliers de personnes
en france
voilà pourquoi après avoir étudié les
fondement juridique de ces interdictions
arbitraires de visites
j'ai proposé dans une tribune publiée
par marianne 10 février dernier
l'instauration d'un droit opposable aux
visites des proches pour les patients
hospitalisés avec stéphanie bataille
nous avons co fondé le collectif tenir
ta main il a pour but d'alerter sur les
dérives éthiques que nous connaissons
depuis maintenant plus d'un an
à ce jour nous avons reçu plus de 8000
témoignages nous en recevons tous les
jours ils sont poignants je pourrais
vous le communiqué
vous êtes 45 une personne vont signer
notre pétition demandant un droit de
visite
c'est donc désormais un sujet de société
et c'est au nom de ces 8000 personnes
qu'ils ont écrits de toutes celles qui
sont le plus hanté victimes de cette
situation que je m'exprime aujourd'hui
qu'on va revenir sur les considérations
juridiques le droit de visite est un
droit du patient ça comme cela a été
rappelé le patient qui peut d'ailleurs
les refuser cependant la police des
visites qui est laissée aux pouvoirs du
directeur donc c'est l'article r 1100
12-47 du code de la santé publique
laisse la place à des à des
interdictions des restrictions qui sont
souvent arbitraire et disproportionné
elles sont inégalitaires
puisque le respect de ce droit est très
variable selon les établissements et que
les inégalités de traitement se
multiplient elles sont disproportionnées
puisque la balance bénéfices risques est
pour beaucoup défavorables
elles sont arbitraires puisqu'elles sont
souvent liés uniquement à la peur de
poursuites médico-légal de la part des
directions et surtout ces limitations
sont difficilement attaquable sur le
plan juridique
en l'absence de possibilité de recours
et cela laisse les proches dans une
situation de désarroi de détresse je ne
reviendrai pas sur l'impact considérable
sur la société entraîne ces restrictions
de visites non seulement pour les
patients eux mêmes
nous avons beaucoup de syndrome de
glissement de personnes qui se laisse
dépérir par solitude par perte de lien
aussi sur les proches qui sont laissés
dans des traumatismes indicible une
forme de culpabilité de ne pas avoir
fait plus pour chercher à atteindre sont
proches et aussi pour la société toute
entière
on a beaucoup de personnes qui refusent
aujourd'hui de se faire soigner par peur
de finir seul donc ça devient vraiment
un sujet de santé publique
et j'ajoute que les conséquences sont
aussi terrible sur les soignants
notamment ceux qui subissent ces
protocoles et qui sont contraints de les
faire appliquer et beaucoup nous indique
vouloir quitter cette profession car ils
ne veulent plus subir ces protocoles
inhumain voilà pourquoi il nous paraît
indispensable de légiférer de légiférer
rapidement pourquoi légiférer
tout d'abord un texte de loi sur le
sujet aurait une évidemment une portée
symbolique inscrire ce droit de visite
dans le code de la santé publique alors
qu'il n'est aujourd'hui que reconnus
dans la charte de la personne
hospitalisée sur est une manière de le
consacrer comme droit fondamental
cela permettrait aussi une norme lisible
et intelligible à l'opposé du flou
législatif et réglementaire qui prévaut
aujourd'hui évidemment une loi de 15
serait aussi une mécanique réglementaire
qui permettrait que ce droit soit bien
assurée dans les établissements de santé
sachant que je le précise contrairement
aux ehpad mais c'est les établissements
de santé il n'y eut aucun texte
réglementaire depuis le début de cette
pandémie
on nage en plein flou juridique ce qui
permet malheureusement à certaines
directions d'établissement exercer une
forme d'arbitraire
et surtout la loi est l'instrument de
recours ultime elle donnerait un solide
socle juridique aux victimes
j'ai entendu dans une intervention
précédente une crainte sur la génération
de contentieux je pense au contraire que
la loi est le dernier recours des plus
faibles face à l'arbitraire médical et
donc il faut que les équipes ainsi
exposé évidemment à assumer leurs
responsabilités et je pense que la loi
leur donnerait évidemment à ce que le
juridique solide
enfin la norme a des vertus de
garde-fous évidemment elle nécessite à
un travail de pédagogie d'appropriation
par les équipes et les usagers mais ce
serait une
une manière de de faire respecter ce
droit fondamental qu'est le droit de
visite surtout à la proche de la mort
nous pourrons y revenir mais les les
témoignages que nous recevons aux
allemands s'impliquent et personnels
montre bien qu'il s'agit désormais d'un
sujet de société
nous avons une seule crainte c'est que
cette situation perdure au delà de la
pandémie
voilà pourquoi il est important d'agir
ce n'est pas une loi de circonstance
mais une loi pour faire assurer tout
simplement des principes élémentaires de
notre civilisation
il est vital aujourd'hui d'assurer un
lien vital entre le patient et ses
proches surtout à la proche de la mort
nous vous remercie c'est vraiment et
pour terminer monsieur pascal champvert
président de l'association des
directeurs au service des personnes
âgées
ses chansons toutes mes excuses oui on
vous entend très mal on vous entend très
mal soit efforts on monte le son de
votre micro ça vous rapprocher de votre
ordinateur mais leçons et prendre au jeu
est ce que vous vous entendez bien
est-ce que vous
bien est-ce que vous
et mes yeux je présenterai mes excuses
d'avoir coupé l'image et vous voyez que
contre lille prennent que j'ai même avec
le son j'ai bien fait d'avoir copié
l'image ont très rapidement la dépasser
2000 directeur d'établissement de
services à domicile dans toute la france
est pour vous dire de quel point de vue
nous parlons de points de quel point de
vue je parle dès le début de la crise
nous avions craint un délire hyper
sécuritaire et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avions saisi le comité
consultatif national d'éthique qui a
d'ailleurs très rapidement donné une un
premier avis au mois d'avril et nous
avions dès le début de la crise dit
qu'il fallait trouver le bon équilibre
entre sécurité et liberté et entre
sécurité psychique et sécurité physique
en fait ce que nous pensons à l'ad-pa et
si je l'avais dit devant votre
commission quand nous étions intervenus
sur les mythes que vides c'est que la
crise est au fond un moment où le passé
présente sa note et je voudrais brossé
très très rapidement le contexte dans
lequel nous sommes tout d'abord il faut
bien voir que nous sommes dans un
contexte d'une société qui agissent tu
sais quoi l'âgisme
c'est une discrimination comme le
racisme le sexisme l'antisémitisme ou
d'autres discriminations
quelques remarques il est courant dans
notre société de dire faudrait pas
vieillir imagine-t-on qu'on dise
faudrait pas être noir faudrait pas être
une femme faudrait pas être homosexuel
quand on compare parfois le sénat une
maison de retraite ses points sauf un
compliment
et vous voyez bien que sa marque cette
discrimination par l'âge et toutes les
discriminations ont des points communs
et je vous invite je vais vous en citer
quelques-uns et je vous invite au moment
où je lis si tu as pensé aux plus
discriminée par l'âge que sont les
personnes très âgées qui vivent ta
domicile ou en établissement
les principes des discriminations c'est
d'abord qui a une séparation entre les
dominants et les dominés les dominant
globalement les jeunes sont totalement
différents des autres et les jeunes
s'agissant là de cette différence avec
les résidents de maisons de retraite
si au fond tous ceux qui ne sont pas en
misant de retour donc on est
complètement séparé de ces gens là qui
sont très différents de nous ils sont
perçus comme radicalement différent et
d'ailleurs le vocabulaire et signifiant
ont dit qu'ils sont dépendants dans une
société où tout le monde se définit
comme indépendant et autonome
les dominer sans tête sont assignés à un
groupe homogène et leur appartenance au
groupe est plus fort que leurs
individualités les dominer sont
considérés c'est essentiel s'agissant
des personnes âgées vulnérables sont
considérés comme ayant des besoins
inférieur aux autres les dominer sont
dévalorisées par les préjugés des autres
et dernier élément derrière toute
discrimination
il y a une peur ou des peurs et il est
bien clair que s'agissant de la
discrimination par l'âge je ne développe
pas il y a la peur de vieillir et la
peur de la mort
deuxième élément de contexte on dit
parfois les établissements ce sont les
invisibles mais pas du tout j'ai aussi
longtemps cru ça et je ne comprenais pas
quand je disais que j'étais directeurs
d'établissements et de services à
domicile
pourquoi systématiquement tous mes
interlocuteurs ne me parlait que des
établissements alors je croyais m'être
mal exprimé j'ai au fil du temps dit
j'étais directeur deux services à
domicile et d'établissements mais on ne
me parlait toujours que d'établissements
pour une raison simple les
établissements sont visibles ce sont les
personnes à domicile qui ne le sont pas
au fond la fonction du domicile faudrait
beaucoup de temps pour développer je
vous présente sa à la halle a très
rapidement et je pourrais développer
dans vos questions au fond dans une
société qui ne veut pas voir le vieux le
vieux valide
il peut être mythifié penser à edgar
morin ou elle une renault alors qu'à
chacune de leurs interviews on explique
qu'ils sont des jeunes
line renaud à 80 ans edgar morin a 100
ans
et les autres c'est-à-dire les vieux qui
vont pas bien et bien au fond ils sont
assignés à rester dans leur domicile là
où on ne les verra pas et au fond c'est
les vieux en établissement qu'on voit
c'est les vues à domicile qu'on vous
qu'on ne voit pas troisième élément les
établissements maison c'est d'ailleurs
les services à domicile sont des lieux
de contradictions fort ce sont des lieux
où père sécurité sans les moyens alors
je ne développerai pas sur la question
des moyens j'y reviendrai dans la
conclusion sur les questions de l'hyper
sécurité il faut bien comprendre que
nous sommes tous dans la liberté pour
nous et dans la sécurité pour les gens
que nous aimons vous voyez par exemple
ces gens qui font du ski hors piste sur
la tête parmi vous ils font du ski hors
piste pour eux au plaisir de la liberté
qu'ils en retirent la plupart d'entre
eux disent je ne veux pas que mes
enfants en face c'est beaucoup trop
dangereux
certains même des conseils à leurs
conjoints en faire parce que c'est
dangereux
liberté pour nous sécurité pour ceux
qu'on aime sécurité pour ce qu'on aime
c'est bien toute la logique des
structures pour personnes âgées
au fond on dit les personnes âgées sont
abandonnés par les familles ce faux il
ya toujours cinq à dix pour cent de
famille très dysfonctionnel et parfois
de personnes âgées qui ont été
dysfonctionnelle quand elle était jeune
mais dans l'immense majorité des cas les
enfants aiment leurs parents la france
n'aime pas ces vieux la société n'aime
pas c'est vieux mais chaque français
globalement mc vieux et donc ce n'est
pas par manque d'amour que l'on veut
la sécurité pour nos parents ou nos
grands parents c'est précisément par
amour mais le problème fondamental c'est
que cet amour est un amour qui enferme
et donc on est dans une sécurité pour
l'autre et ce qui est assignée aux
établissements pour personnes âgées y
compris par la législation par le droit
par les lois ou par les décrets encore
plus par les arrêter les circulaires
c'est une injonction de sécurité dans
précisément des établissements où les
gens sont les plus âgés c'est à dire
ceux qui sont les plus susceptibles de
mourir
alors pendant cette crise il y a eu
clairement des établissements totalement
hors jeu certains établissements mais
aussi des responsables de la profession
disais au début de la crise et c'est ça
qui nous a fait réagir
nous ferons des établissements des
citadelles dans lequel le virus
n'entrera pas quand on fait des
citadelles en société démocratique
c'est qu'on ressort qu'on sort de la
société démocratique
même s'il y avait des raisons objectives
ça a été dit par mes prédécesseurs
d'avoir peur dire en société
démocratique qu'on fait des citadelles
c'est sortir du jeu démocratique et ça
montre bien à quel point dans ce milieu
déjà très sécuritaire la crise a été une
occasion dix paires sécuriser encore
plus ce qui a été ce qui est déjà trop
sécurisées ensuite en dehors de ces
établissements qui clairement se sont
placés jeudi en dehors de la démocratie
il ya une minorité mais réelle
d'établissement qui étaient englués par
la peur alors n'oublions pas que ces
peurs elle avait aussi un support au
début de la crise il n'y avait pas de
test il n'y avait pas de masque et il a
été raconté tout à l'heure je crois par
marc dupont comment à l'hôpital quelques
appuis arrivé à son corps défendant et
transmettre le virus à une dizaine de
personnes mais cette logique sécuritaire
elle a été décuplée par ce qu'elle n'est
celle se développait sur un terreau
sécuritaire alors pour conclure
faut-il des des faut-il légiférer
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs oui
incontestablement
mais ce que nous pensons c'est qu'il ne
faut pas légiférer que pour la prochaine
crise il faut légiférer pour tous les
jours et en fait ce que nous pensons
c'est que l'anomalie des établissements
pour personnes âgées
c'est précisément que ce sont des
établissements songez que dans la
première crise les seuls français
aujourd'hui poursuivis sont des
ministres et des directeurs
d'établissements pour personnes âgées
penser que pendant la crise de la
canicule 15000 morts
le sol français qui a été poursuivi par
la justice
c'était là directeurs d'établissements
pour personnes âgées c'est à dire des
directeurs qui sont poursuivis parce que
dans la structure qu'il dirige des gens
sont décédés
mais aucun maire aucun président de
département fort heureusement et aucun
président de région ne sont poursuivis
parce qu'il y a eu des morts sur le
territoire qu'ils administrent en fait
cette logique d'établissement qui rend
responsable un directeur est aussi son
équipe le directeur n'est jamais seul le
médecin était ses équipes est un système
qui fait que dès lors qu'il ya un risque
juridique et ce risque il est vécu très
fortement par l'ensemble de la
profession
dès lors qu'il ya un risque juridique
inévitablement cela développe des
volontés par peur de protéger de fer
qu'il n'y ait pas de morts dans un
secteur où c'est au sens philosophique
une aporie c'est à dire une impasse de
l'esprit parce que nous ne sommes pas
dans des écoles maternelles ou les
jeunes enfants des probabilité très
faible de mourir nous sommes précisément
dans des établissements qui accueillent
des personnes qui sont très âgés qui
donc sont en probabilité de mourir
prochainement
donc en conclusion transformant les
établissements en domicile regrouper
c'est ce qu'ont fait les danois et c'est
certainement le pays le plus avancé en
matière de protection des personnes
âgées et faisons en sorte qu'en devenant
des domiciles
ces établissements ça a été dit par
certains des prédécesseurs soient de
vrais habitat de vrai lieu de vie dans
le droit commun et vous verrez que les
difficultés que nous avons rencontrées
dans la crise avec les établissements
nous ne les rencontrerons plus du tout
de la même façon je conclue d'un mot les
résidences services seniors les
résidences autonomie c'est un petit peu
moins que sept mille établissements pour
personnes âgées
c'est de l'ordre de 5000 mais tout de
même ça n'est pas rien nous n'avons
absolument pas entendu parler pendant
cette crise parce qu'ils ont un statut
d'établissement donc pour conclure
définitivement
on peut reprendre l'immense majorité
quasiment la totalité des propositions
de la défenseure des droits y compris
celle qui dit
qu'il faut mettre un ratio minimum de
professionnels dans les établissements
et j'ajouterais mais c'est un autre
débat aussi dans les services à domicile
merci de votre attention merci beaucoup
donc merci à 20,5 pour pour ces propos
qui vont lancer les questions à la une
deux trois qu une dizaine de sénateurs
on va faire un groupe de 5,6 comme il ya
cinq 5 intervenants
si les collègues peuvent à peu près
cibler la la personne si oui ou non elle
concilie mais ciblé la personne à qui
s'adresse la question ça peut être
plusieurs personnes mais mais cibler les
personnes à qui vous adressez qu'on
n'est pas cinq réponses à chaque
question
voilà donc michel meunier merci madame
la présidente
écoutez les derniers propos par monsieur
champvert me rappelle expressément le
travail que nous avons fait avec mon
collègue bernard bonne puisque né austin
nous avons cité l'exemple danois sur une
nouvelle prise en charge en tout cas une
prise en charge bien différente des
personnes âgées dans notre société mais
là je n'ai pas le le sujet en tout cas
merci monsieur champvert pour la ferveur
de vos propos moi je voulais surtout pas
questionner mais en tout cas revenir sur
les propos de mr gilles du début de
cette audition de son point de vue
éthique qui me rappellent fortement
l'espace éthique pays de la loire de
notre de votre collègue denis deniaud
qui soulève ce point de cette
exacerbation de la situation des ehpad
en particulier secteur hospitalier
sûrement aussi par la crise c'est à dire
l'état dans laquelle étaient déjà ces
établissements par leur manque de
personnel enfin tout ça c'est d'une
banalité puisque d'autres des rapports
appareils comrie qui ont pointé tous ces
manques et donc la crise a mis en
évidence ce terrain un peu fertile pour
la maltraitance des personnes pour aller
vite et c'est vrai que quand on pense
que il faut plus de temps qu'il faut un
accompagnement individuel à une
résidente pour des soins de nursing pour
son alimentation pour son déplacement
évidemment quand un an de crise tout ça
et encore une fois donc mis en avant
alors c'est paradoxal parce qu'on se
rappelle tous de l'image de maurice
atteint ou vous souvenez qui a été la
première française à se faire vacciner
en décembre et puis toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont suivi puisqu'il ya eu
un taux il ya un taux très important de
vacciner dans les ehpad
mais pourquoi au final puisque les
restrictions sont importantes les
protocoles de visites sont parfois
toxiques en jeu j'emploie le mot pour
les relations et les tas de relations
entre la famille et le résident et donc
tout ça tout ça en fait pourquoi
pourquoi vacciner pourquoi avoir fait
toute cette campagne réussie de
vaccination pour maintenir les
restrictions alors ma question elle est
un peu simple et un peu caricatural
est-ce qu'il faut une loi pour maintenir
les droits de visite ou est-ce qu'il
faut donner aux établissements les
moyens d'intégrer dans leur accueil
les visites qui font partie de la vie
des hôpitaux honda charte et des ehpad
également donc voila moi je moi je
serais plutôt pour mais vous le savez
avoir une war autonomie et grand âge qui
donne les moyens aux structures au
domicile et au service qui gère les
personnes âgées d'exercer la démocratie
sanitaire qui manque considérablement en
france c'est un ami l'ont déjà merci
mon intervention le début de mon
intervention va choquer la dernière
personne qui est intervenu c'est à dire
que malgré mon âge et bien que je sois
au sénat je vais avoir un discours de
dominants je veux dire par là que je
rejoins un peu madame meunier sur le
fait que tout ce qui a été fait pendant
cette crise a été bien fait mais
insuffisamment frais par faute de moyens
par faute de personnel et s'il ya pas de
moyens pas de personnel c'est bien parce
que le parlement et les gouvernements
successifs ont vanté ont voté des honda
hm qui n'étaient pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'il fallait faire
quelles que soient les parlements et l
équipe quelles que soient les majorités
pardon et quels que soient les
gouvernements en place
donc nous sommes tous un peu on est
d'accord le rang 7 sud nous sommes tous
un peu fautif alors jeté le remarque que
pour ce qui me concerne je vais pas
souvent voté les professeurs étaient et
donc je voudrais revenir on assure une
phrase je rejoins complètement
complètement ce qu'a dit le professeur
cécile man man o man à wil excusez moi
si je prononce pas de votre non madame
mais je vous rejoins complètement je
voudrais juste sans poser de questions
cité une phrase que j'aime beaucoup que
j'ai retrouvée parce que je la connais
pas par coeur et quelquefois nécessaire
de changer certaines lois mais le cas
est rare et lorsqu'ils arrivent et ni
faut toucher
il ne faut toucher que d'une main
tremblante c'est de montesquieu disait
ça alors ne changeait pas
systématiquement toutes les lois parce
que les circonstances font que vérifiez
bien que si vous tous vous touchez la
loi vous y mettez un côté les moyens
nécessaires pour qu'elle puisse être pic
merci c'était plus une salle à saint
laurent
oui moi je vais j'ai continué en fait
dans la même philosophie que michel
meunier alain milon parce que
effectivement je suis très dubitatif sur
le fait de légiférer ou pas je le dis
donc j'attends aussi cette cette
audition comme pouvant justement
dissiper les doutes en réalité pourquoi
parce que je trouve que effectivement il
ya on le voit au niveau de notre système
de santé un manque de moyens criant ça
vous ne serais pas étonné parce que au
niveau de mon groupe avec katia
pourceaux poli on le défend tout le
temps mais mais je pense aussi qu'il ya
une histoire de conception et notamment
de la prise en charge des personnes
âgées
moi ce qui m'a beaucoup choqué parmi
d'autres choses mais durant durant cette
crise c'est que les personnes vivant en
ehpad toutacoo sont devenus des
personnes privées de leur droit et je
trouve qu'ils ont été c'est comme si
finalement considéré ces personnes ces
pensionnaires comme des gens mineurs et
je trouve qu'on a réfléchi entre
protéger mais en préservant la liberté
je trouve qu'on a retiré toute liberté
de pouvoir choisir d'avoir ou pas des
visites
on leur a dit c'est comme ça et on les a
totalement isolé et je crois que c'est
c'est monsieur frémont d'ailleurs qui a
dit qu'on avait assisté et nous on l'a
constaté sur nos territoires et puis
lors des auditions n'a constaté
effectivement des glissements des
syndrome de glissement et des gens qui
se sont laissées mourir ne sont pas
mortes
ils sont pas mortes de l'aco vide ils
sont morts de tristesse de solitude etc
et ça a imputé ses passions mais ça a
impacté les personnels aussi parce
qu'ils ont assisté impuissants à ça donc
voila et comment
on légifère dans ce contexte là en
préservant quand même à la fois la
possibilité pour les établissements
d'avoir une certaine latitude aussi donc
comment on fait pour faire en sorte que
effectivement illégalité qui règne au
niveau de l'ensemble du territoire parce
qu'aujourd'hui comme l'a dit monsieur
frémont n'y a pas d'égalité 1 c suivant
les établissements suivants le
territoire etc
il ya des règles totalement différente
des protocoles qui sont qui sont
extrêmement pesant et donc comment on
arrive à à concilier tout ça moi ça me
c'est ça qui me pose problème dans le
cadre du dunois de comment on arrive à
concilier les choses et puis je me pose
une autre question c'est que healy a
effectivement la situation des ehpad et
puis il ya les établissements la
situation des établissements de santé
et là encore je pense que c'est une
autre problématique aujourd'hui
alors là je serai enfin je demande aux
collègues qui en plus sont médecins qui
ont peut-être une connaissance plus
pointus là dessus il me semble
qu'aujourd'hui dans les établissements
hospitaliers hors crise on a le droit
quand on a le droit de signer une
décharge par exemple si on veut quitter
l'établissement hospitalier
mais qu'est-ce quid de la période de
qu'ovide quand on entend des témoignages
et on en a eu aussi lors de nos
permanences de gens qui n'ont pas pu de
familles qui n'ont pas pu malgré leurs
demandes
à les voir lors leur leurs maris leurs
frères leurs pairs etc ou qui était
hospitalisée pour qu ils là il n'y a pas
eu de possibilités y compris pour les
patients qui étaient qui avaient toutes
leurs leur sens de pouvoir se signer des
décharges
donc c'est quoi ta lll voilà donc moi je
me pose des questions là et je me dis
est-ce que c'est par la loi ou
finalement banon donc je vois ces jeux
désolé je fait pas avancer les choses
mais mais je pense que l'audition peut
peut-être nous éclairer et je peux avoir
des réponses à ces questions mais c'est
surtout maintenir quand même la liberté
des patients parce que comme l'a dit on
un défenseur des droits il ya dix ans il
ya eu des entailles absolument
terrifiante
c'est vrai qu'il ya plusieurs étapes ya
la fois la visite dans les ehpad de
personnes qui ont un terreau des visites
pour pas contaminer l'intérieur de
l'ehpad et les résidents et et mais il
ya quand même ce point très particulier
que vous avez fort bien décrit monsieur
ferait manquer celui de ces gens qui ont
été prises et même de 2,2 de dire un
dernier adieu aux à la personne décédée
on le connaît tous des gens qui au
surtout au début de la pandémie où la
personne est décédée personne ne l'a
revu
sayah corps est ce que c'est un problème
de loi ce problème je ne sais quoi
enfin ça c'est quand même produit un
moment il faut y trouver une solution
parce que là on est dans l'inhumanité
total total se dire ce que vous décrivez
est absolument cauchemardesque et on se
demande comment on peut accepter quand
on sait qu'une fois que la personne est
décédée
il y avait des possibilités quand même
sans prendre de risques énormes que les
gens qui situe alors ça je sais pas on
aura ce débat lorsque les textes à ripon
on a sans doute le débat lorsque tu es
sur l'urgence va arriver pour en effet
si on doit on doit amener des
amendements concernant
c'est un panel assez large que celui
qu'on évoque ce matin parce que ça va de
la visite des visites contées restreint
de personnes qui sont fait verbalisé
parce qu'ils étaient à la fenêtre pour
pourparlers alors marié à travers la
chine est au départ il ya eu des tas de
camille a quand même ce point très
particulier des derniers instants
aulas il faut à mon sens trouver une
solution à ce qui se passe par la loi ce
qui passe par autre chose à nos débats
le diront jusqu'à une vitesse
oui merci à mme la présidente
- la question va s'adresser à madame un
film à nous ils voulaient évoquer et je
vous en remercie en tous les cas les
établissements qui accueillent des
personnes handicapées je pense en effet
que les abus ont été aussi dans
dans ces centrales a certainement par
manque de personnel mais j'ai aussi des
protocoles trop pesant aussi bien pour
les aidants que pour les personnes qui
étaient accueillis
ma question est celle-ci ne croyez vous
pas que de mettre un des lecteurs pour
trois établissements ce n'est pas trop
je pense que aujourd'hui comme ça à ce
directeur
la difficulté c'est qu'il ne sait pas ce
qui se passe dans ces établissements
puisque ce sont des chefs de service
qu'ils sont
je vais vous dire que j'ai reçu de
nombreux courriers par rapport à cela
voilà c'est vraiment ma question est ce
que enfin un directeur pour trois
établissements sais pas trop merci merci
madame la présidente
merci à nos intervenants je voudrais
remercier monsieur frémont pour son
témoignage parce que sais je sais que
c'est pas facile de venir parler de sa
situation personnelle que c'est émouvant
et c'est révoltant surtout et d'ailleurs
je pense visiblement un peu comme
catherine de roche que peut-être que ce
à quoi vous avez été confrontés c'est à
l'abolition du principe d'humanité et je
sais pas s'il ya une loi pour empêcher
ça par contre je sais qu'il ya des
régulation et dérégulation des
professions de santé qui vise à
justement mettre des limites et je ne
sais pas si vous avez saisies très
clairement lors des médecins dont on
aimerait qu'il soit particulièrement
actif dans ce cas là pour faire
respecter ce qui est ce principe
d'humanité et inscrit malgré tout dans
des textes législatifs puisque dans le
code de déontologie notamment mais ça va
être ma première question ceci dit moi
je ne je ne perçois pas je fais la
différence entre les hôpitaux qui sont
des lieux de soins ont ces joutes
transitoirement et les ehpad qui sont
des lieux de vie pour ce qui est des
hôpitaux
est ce que le problème se pose avec la
même acuité au delà
de dérives comme celles monsieur
vraiment où nous avait rapporté mais est
ce que ces dérives reste limitée ou est
ce que il ya vraiment une question on va
dire d'ordre général qu'il faut régler
par un dispositif qui peut être la loi
en l'occurrence c'est une question à
laquelle moi je n'ai pas la réponse
aujourd'hui parce que je veux aussi et
j'ai constater par moi même d'ailleurs
que beaucoup de soignants n'appliquaient
pas ces protocoles pour des raisons d'
humanité et ont ont permis aux gens de
venir voir leurs proches et ça a été un
comportement heureusement répandu aussi
dans un établissement de soins donc est
ce qu'il ya une question dans les
hôpitaux qui se posent
j'aimerais je ne sais pas d'ailleurs qui
d'entre vous pourrez vais répondre moi
je n'ai pas la réponse à cette question
ma deuxième question elle pose sur la
question l'ade et des ehpad
pourquoi est-ce que des dispositifs
limite limitative de liberté qui était
compréhensible au début de crise parce
qu'il fallait sauver des vies je sais
que c'est plus très à la mode de sauver
des vies dans la gestion de l'épidémie
mais il fallait sauver des vies est donc
partout dans toute la société
des restrictions de liberté ont été
apposées à quel moment on a basculé à
cet instant où comme le rappelait michel
au fond il n'ya plus vraiment de
légitimité à la restriction de liberté
pourtant il continue et pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'habitue à cette
restriction de liberté
peut-être ça fait écho aux propos de
monsieur champvert d'ailleurs sur cette
espèce d'arbitrage qu'on connaît bien de
balançon connais bien entre la sécurité
à la liberté
et peut-être que on finit par s'habituer
à fort sarov de rechercher un risque
zéro à accepter que nos libertés soient
structurellement entaché le je ne sais
pas mais je il ya une vraie question la
troisième question que j'ai fait est ce
qu'au fond concernant les ehpad cette
crise ce qu'elle nous raconte c'est que
ce modèle de prise en charge de nos
personnes âgées qu'on concentre dans des
lieux n'est pas un peu
ses passes il faut dire à bout de
souffle en tout cas fini par être
contreproductif et on a assisté tous ces
dernières années enfin on peut dire plus
de 10 ans même un mouvement de
concentration qui s'est accrue puisque
tous les élus locaux connaissent ça
quand il faut qu'on soit un ehpad à ben
oui mais 60 places et pas assez rentable
on peut pas il en faut 100 120 en
dessous vous comprenez le foncier machin
etc voilà et à l'arrivée on visse en
même temps les frais de personnel 11 %
seulement des ehpad ans une infirmière
l'année on sait on sait bien donc parler
de soins palliatifs d'ailleurs on en
parlera après devient une plaisanterie
et que c'était à mais est ce que au fond
et moi j'aimerais avoir votre avis
là-dessus
est ce qu'on doit par visite et de façon
plus profonde est ce qui va nous
interroger tous personnellement pour le
coup ce modèle de concentration des
personnes âgées dans un même lieu un
échec mais on y met mais c'était le
rapport inexact mais c'est madame la
présidente
déjà je voulais remercier les
intervenants ils ont mis des paroles
finalement et confirmer ce que nous
entendons tout son terrain et on les a
entendus avec une certaine émotion je
dois le dire alors merci pour votre
analyse aux propositions même qui nous
sommes tous un peu dans le doute sur sur
ce qu'il faut faire
elle était forte envie de trouver des
solutions moi j'ai deux questions à
poser ou de 2 témoigne un chercheur déjà
je me demande pourquoi ils se comptaient
nalyse jacques c des branches en période
sanitaires notamment sim sont vaccinés
alors qu'on oblige toujours pas les
soignants à faire accéder des gens qu'il
ya quelque chose d'illogique dans cette
situation là et puis j'aurais nos
remarques à faire là on a beaucoup parlé
de l'accès des proches ou
d'établissement pendant la crise
sanitaire
mais inversement j'ai des remontées
ça se passait son week-end de pâques
notamment mais il y en a eu d'autres
une résidente vacciner les 94 ans qui
devait rejoindre ses d'enfants vaccinés
aussi et on veut imposer à son retour à
l'isolément complet d'hui jours alors là
aussi une sente qui a cessé complètement
illogique et ceux des situations je
pense qu'il faudrait prendre en compte
aussi si on propose une modification des
règlements ou je ne sais quoi parce que
sinon bon voilà on peut demander à quoi
bon vaccinés qui s'adonnent pas un petit
peu plus de liberté voilà les lieux
remet à je souhaitais faire on va
s'arrêter là pour commencer les les
réponses on aura ensuite si merci
leclerc on a ensuite sim six collègues
qui interviendront également dont
peut-être madame manon will sur le les
problèmes des questions de jeu sanitaire
sur les établissements accueillant des
personnes handicapées est conscient d'un
directeur pour tran alors c'est pas
l'objet merci madame c'est pas lou reed
et des ppn mais de toute façon plus plus
il ya de personnel on se dit mieux ce
sera mais là moi je voulais rebondir sur
le fait qu'on disait y est ce qu'il faut
une loi ou un toit et on sait très bien
que le fait d'instaurer des droits dans
la loi ça ne suffit pas s'il n'y a pas
les moyens derrière et puis il n'ya pas
non plus de sanction derrière
concrètement on peut faire le parallèle
avec l'accès au dossier du patient
depuis la loi du 4 mars 2002 tous les
patients ont accès à leur dossier
médical
n'empêche que dans le rapport du
défenseur des droits etc
on voit que ça régulièrement c'est à si
simple que ça et que 20 ans après
bientôt vingt ans après la loi kouchner
il ya encore des difficultés dans
certains établissements pour avoir accès
au dossier
si demain on instaure par la loi un
droit de visite hebdomadaire
ce sera pas toujours si simple et donc
il faut il faut il faut il faut de la
souplesse aussi il faut donner le risque
de le noter dans la loi pour les
établissements de santé
c'est que ça entraîne des procédures
pesant et il faut toujours laisser un
peu de souplesse a été évoquée
heureusement que oui il ya des médecins
qui ont laissé des personnes venir
et puis aujourd'hui il ya quand même un
peu plus de souplesse justement dans lé
serbe et il ya dans les établissements
de santé aujourd'hui les visites sont
encore très restreint mais il dans
notamment dans les services de
cancérologie
mais à les cerner les visites sont
autorisées alors parfois c'est une seule
personne qui peuvent dire un meilleur
une personne qui était autorisé à venir
dans les services de soins palliatifs et
puis dans les derniers jours en poule
considère ces les derniers jours de vie
est en fin de vie il ya des médecins qui
autorise à venir et tant mieux qu'ils la
souplesse de dire est juste un mot
encore pour y répondre il avait été
évoquée l'ordre des médecins alors
justement moi au moins je suis médecin
et je vois quand même beaucoup de
procédures faire des expertises et ses
contres contre les médecins et fr les
recours au niveau du conseil de l'ordre
sur les si demain on instaure le droit
de visite dans la loi est également dans
la déontologie médicale faire des
recours au niveau du conseil de londres
pour ça je suis pas sûr que ça résout
grand chose
concrètement à l'hôpital le médecin
hospitalier qui a refusé la visite
il dira le protocole c'est le directeur
d'établissement qui l'a fait le
directeur d'établissement il faut
réfléchir assure des consignes de
sécurité et comme toujours on est sur un
équilibre entre la sécurité et et puis
la liberté
donc voilà alors est juste un mot elle
était évoquée alors des décharges
c'est pas des décharges cd sorti contre
avis médical si toujours possible on
peut sortir de l'hôpital à tout moment à
part quand on est hospitalisé sous
contrainte en psychiatrie
mais en dehors de ça on peut sortir en
signant une sortie contre avis médical
ça ça reste possible avec un texte quand
même essayer l'article l
3131 tirer 1 du code de la santé
publique qui prévoit que le préfet sur
des maladies infectieuses justement
puisse imposer un suivi médical mais
mais mais sinon on peut sortir contre
avis médical
oui avant que pour compléter mois
puisque vous êtes beaucoup dans le
procès du contentieux
votre avis sur l'obligation vaccinale
déçoit les soignants alors moi je suis
pour moi je pense qu'il fait
exclusivement ça me choque énormément
que dans les ehpad et un taux de
vaccination qui soit plus élevé chez les
résidents que chez les soignants et on
sait que chez les soignants plus on
descend dans la hiérarchie mais voilà
les aides soins sont vaccinés que les
infirmières et les infirmières sont
moins faciles avec les médecins moi je
suis pour une une obligation de
vaccination mais c'est toujours
compliqué aussi parce que fait le
parallèle avec la grid pour la grippe ça
avait été introduit dans la loi et
ensuite ça a été suspendu donc
aujourd'hui la grippe elle est notée
dans la loi mais il ya une suspension
donc alors pourquoi l'on commet oui moi
je suis pour la vaccination obligatoire
des soignants contre la copie bien
monsieur vraiment vous pourrez peut-être
répondre sur par rapport à la question
de bernard janvier
dans les plus que vous dites vous avez
un nombre important de témoignages
qu'elle est un peu le type de témoignage
si vous pouvez les classer rapidement et
en quoi un effet la loi vous apparaît
importante par rapport à ce que vous
avez pu vivre
si vous voulez un témoignage reçu hier
soir au chu de poitiers en ce moment mon
père est hospitalisé pour un cancer de
l'oesophage ce jour seule ma mère mon
père un jour eux nous les enfants
d'avoir aucun droit de visite
je ne sais pas comment faire pour avoir
ce droit de visite mon souhait le plus
cher était d'accompagner mon père dans
les derniers moments de sa vie
je suis en colère et scandalisé et si
fin si vous voulez savoir ce vraiment
des dizaines tous les jours et
représentatif mais surtout on a vraiment
l'impression que les personnes sont
totalement désemparé puisque le
justement le droit n'est pas assez clair
il reste flou qui n'a jamais eu de
recommandations sur le sujet donc c'est
pour ça que ça me semble utile de au
moins rappelé le principe est de et de
sortir de ce flou juridique
sachant que bon on n'a pas des vaccins
pour les ehpad mais pour le pour
l'établissement sortir d'un thème des
tests en ce qui me concerne voilà on
était en novembre mais mes questions
testés négatifs mon père aussi à ce
qu'on là qu'est ce qui justifie
l'interdiction de visite
et donc voilà les enfin les témoignages
que nous recevons sont vraiment très
divers il reconnaît des situations très
variées mais ce qui ressort avant tout
c'est que les gens sont dévastés à des
gens si vous voulez la ans après
une dame qui n'a pas pu voir son père
avant sa mort je cherche pas pas dans
toutes les silhouettes d'hommes que je
croise on ne sait jamais s'il n'était
pas mort s'ils s'étaient trompés comment
être sûr on ne l'a pas vu il aurait été
mis dans une housse même pas billets
personne de l'hôpital nous a jamais
appelé il est mort et voilà c'est tout
notre boulot s'arrête là où est
l'humanité et fall et les dégâts le
traumatisme sur société est considérable
donc c'est pour ça qu'un jour j'en vois
et j'entends tout à fait vos voix au
débat
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le pouvoir qui
laissait aux directeurs d'établissements
et d'ailleurs madame parlait des
contentieux contre les soignants ma
non les pouvoirs de police restent aux
mains des directeurs d'établissements
donc ce serait des contentieux qui
s'adresserait à l'encontre des
directions et bien pouvoir est
aujourd'hui arbitraire et donc il
conviendrait enfin voila je comprends
tout à fait pour des motifs d'ordre
public des motifs sanitaires on puisse
restreindre les visites dans des
contextes particuliers mais il faut en
finalement encadrer ce pouvoir de
restrictions et le et le clarifier pour
sortir de l' arbitraire de ces
situations qui sont disproportionnées
inégalitaire et pour ce qui est du
dialogue avec les ordres des médecins
mais on est déjà en contact avec
notamment les fédérations et évidemment
que c'est avant tout une question de
moyens humains et matériels et de
protocoles d'ailleurs on en propose ont
travaillé avec des soignants mais je
pense qu'avant tout il faut quand même
réaffirmé le principe est il inscrit
comme un droit fondamental pour les
passions j'étais quatre points très
rapide la première c'est comme le disait
madame meunier effectivement la crise a
accentué les difficultés qui étaient
déjà présentes et ont peu difficile mais
beaucoup de répondant nous l'ont dit on
peut difficilement accompagner dignement
et humainement sans personnel en nombre
suffisant formés compétents et c'est
pour ça c'est sans quoi et si on occulte
cette question des moyens
on culpabilise les professionnels et
c'est vraiment doublement injuste
ensuite je suis d'accord qu'il ya des
situations abusives qui perdure y
compris alors que beaucoup de personnes
sont vaccinées et en même temps ce qui
nous frappe ce sont des différences est
extrêmement importante et moi je
voudrais pas qu'on ressorte de cette
audition avec le sentiment que les ehpad
c'est une situation les hôpitaux c'est
différent je suis actuellement en
immersion dans un service de réanimation
où les visites des familles ont été
maintenus alors que la quasi-totalité de
l'hôpital sont pas possible parce
qu'elle du personnel pour les accueillir
et à ce que l'équipe que l'on considère
que ces extrêmes
important et donc ce qui ce qui
questionne c'est comment on arriverait à
mettre en rapport des gens qui font
différemment pour montrer à ceux qui
pensent que c'est impossible qui
pourrait le faire ensuite effectivement
les résidents des états sont parfois
considérés comme des mineurs est parfois
pire je partage ce sentiment est en même
temps ce n'est pas le cas partout et je
pense qu'il ya des endroits on en a
beaucoup d'exemples nous où les
résidents les familles sont informés en
amont consulter associés aux décisions y
compris aux décisions pendant pendant la
crise aux modalités de la vaccination
aux modalités du déconfinement et là il
ya vraiment un point à suivre alors sur
est ce que c'est de la loire opale la
loi moi j'étais à trois points qui nous
tiennent à coeur
le premier c'est ubu ce que vous avez
dit sur les droits des aidants le droit
des proches le droit des aidants qu'on
appelle les aidants informels la
reconnaissance des droits d aider des
proches au sens très large mais y
compris dans les relations avec les
équipes et je pense que ça c'est quelque
chose que le parlement a déjà porté à
déjà accentuées on peut encore dans
cette lignée là sans doute progresser la
deuxième sujet c'est lui les
possibilités de recours quand vous êtes
comme laurent frémont coup mais comme
beaucoup d'autres gens qui se tournent
vers nous conte il y à des recours mais
dans la pratique ils sont très
difficiles à mettre en oeuvre de manière
rapide et efficace pour pour faire
évoluer les situations comme anvers
qu'elle tiers se tourner pour débloquer
s'en allaient nécessairement aux
conflits et aux idéaux à la mise en
cause juridique des situations bloquées
et troisièmement je pense qu'il faut des
repères et votre assemblée elle en donne
et si sa mission probablement d'en
donner et moi je me suis gêné par le
fait qu'on continue d'opposer sécurité
liberté on est dans un pays où la
sécurité est au service de la liberté
est donc plutôt que d'en permanence de
se demander où on va placer le curseur
entre les deux c'est une manière de les
opposer je pense qu'il faut et salle il
beaucoup de directeurs d'ehpad une
résidence ou de services et de
nos résidences autonomie aussi nous
l'ont demandé dont il a besoin d'un
message sûr c'est quoi la philosophie le
cadre de valeur dans lequel on se place
et si on met toutes les valeurs sur le
même plan cae d'arbitré en permanence et
il n'y arrive pas et je pense que
réaffirmer fortement que la protection
de la sécurité la protection des
personnalités au service d'une liberté
et des libertés je pense que ce sera un
message très très fort adressé qui
remettrait de la clarté au plan des
normes et des valeurs
merci beaucoup monsieur dupont si vous
souhaitez ajouter par rapport aux
questions déjà posées il faut ouvrir
votre micro vous entend pas monsieur
dupont il faut ouvrir votre micro deux
trois choses encore une fois j'insiste
sur le fait que la question d'une loi
sur le droit de visite c'est répondre
est essentiellement à une question
contact de crise parce que je pense
qu'en temps normal cependant les choses
se passent de façon je pense
satisfaisante
je suis content chose c'est par rapport
à là où il a parlé de l' équilibre entre
sécurité et liberté je pense
qu'effectivement la notion d'équilibré
l'importante et j'ai dit je me revient
donc à une approche personnelle mais
aussi d'une vieille mère dans un
établissement et pendant toute la
période de la crise j'étais partagé
entre l' envie de la voir
et sans doute ne sont en vie réelle de
me voir et aussi la grande crainte
d'être coupable pour entourer de mali 1
du fait que j'aurais pu la contaminer
donc je pense que c'est quand même pas
simple dans cette période de trouver cet
équilibre est chacun dans sa propre
expérience personnelle peut être en
difficulté au delà de la difficulté que
peut rencontrer l'établissement pour
gérer ce type de situation
la troisième chose les droits de visite
c'est mon avis ce sera porté à un nombre
plus générale bloqué celui qu'on reprend
au contentieux avec du contentieux c'est
à dire c'est le droit d'un type de 8 de
la convention européenne des droits de
l'homme sur le droit à des relations
familiales la normale ou des relations
sociales
ce droit social par exemple la question
qu'on a eu à l'assistance publique
c'était bien sûr que les familles
puissent venir mais aussi pour les gens
qui n'ont pas de famille
d'avoir les bénévoles qui viennent les
visiter et donc face à des passes aussi
le cercle purement familiales ou des
proches enfin dernière chose il ya un
action à ce sujet sur les derniers
instants pense que c'est sûr que là s'il
ya un droit fondamental c'est bien
effectivement de voir les personnes dans
ses derniers moments mais ça je jeu pour
se dire que c'était une expérience qu'on
a vu dans les hôpitaux paris s'est très
rapidement puis le cce est intervenu là
dessus aussi
c'est vraiment un point qui a été très
important tout de suite que de voir ce
droit de pouvoir avancer moi c'est
encore lui une dernière chose qu'on
parle beaucoup de directeurs c'est
certes il y avait des protocoles ya eu
des textes mais c'est vrai que le droit
de visite il est beaucoup j'ai fait
l'équipe médicale par les responsables
médicaux par les cadres il fallait ou
comme il ya eu beaucoup de depuis ce
fameux qu'ils ont compte des situations
individuelles au cas par cas pour
trouver une solution sur l'ehpad s est
encore un modèle mais certainement pas
pour nous peut-être quelques mots
rapides à voir pour dire à madame
monnier que nous nous retrouvons dans
beaucoup des propositions qu'elle a fait
dans son rapport avec monsieur bonne
notamment évidemment sur le manque de
moyens ce qui rejoint les les questions
de monsieur mi-longs et et madame cohen
est aussi madame dit est ce parce que la
diminution du nombre de directeurs et
leurs groupements d'établissements
ça a été aussi un des éléments de
réponse à à ce manque de moyens autre
élément sur la question de légiférer
en fait la question c'est pas tellement
d'intégrer des lois nouvelles dans
l'établissement c'est d'intégrer les
établissements dans les lois communes et
de ce point de vue c'est pas très loin
de la philosophie qui évoqua boussioux
milan s'est pas légiférer pour légiférer
et légiférer
c'est dire simplement les établissements
pour personnes âgées aujourd'hui on
pourrait sans doute dire la même chose
des établissements pour personnes
handicapées mais c'est absolument pas le
sujet que je que je connais donc je ne
me permettrais pas d'en parler et les
établissements pour personnes âgées
sont des exceptions au point commun et
en cela ils n'ont plus de sens et
j'avais bien en temps j'avais en tête
l'exemple danois aussi cité par madame
monnier et monsieur bonne et quand
madame cohen dit ils sont souvent
considérés comme des mineurs oui c'est
vrai mais parler je dirais par la
société par les textes alors fabriqué il
a parfaitement raison
pas partout bien sûr et à la baie pas
nous militons pour que nos adhérents et
les autres directeurs agissent pour que
soient complètement reconnu la parole
des personnes mais parfois il faut agir
contre la société
et quand on est un jeune directeur quand
on est quand on a des difficultés dans
son établissement quand on est une
équipe fragile quand il ya des médecins
qui sont très sécuritaires ou des
équipes très sécuritaire et ben on peut
pas faire cela et donc malheureusement
c'est l'hyper sécuritaire qui qui domine
et pour répondre à monsieur jomier et
madame jacques mais vous avez
parfaitement raison il n'y a plus aucune
raison pour qu'il continue à y avoir des
restrictions à la vie et aux visites
dans les établissements pour personnes
âgées aujourd'hui puisque ces structures
sont pour une fois plus en avance que le
reste de la société puisque ces lames
sont pour les gens vaccinés ou presque
et bien entendu nous ce que nous
demandons à la ministre c'est de
réformer en profondeur le protocole du
du mois de mars qui a été un proprement
à pic pour te colle de déconfinement
parce qu'il comporte encore beaucoup
d'éléments qui vont dans le sens de des
restrictions et à part les
établissements au milieu des foyers
épidémiques pour lesquels on peut
comprendre qu'après un protocole pour
tous les autres il faut supprimer le
protocole et dernier élément sur
l'obligation vaccinale le professeur
manas où il l'a très bien dit - on est
formé - on est vacciné et moi je serais
extrêmement juste nous sommes totalement
opposés à l'obligation vaccinale
nous pensons qu'il faut faire de la
pédagogie - on est formée - et vaccinés
puis il ya les tables
sur le dise réticence aux vaccins la
réticence au vaccin c'est souvent une
méfiance par rapport aux pouvoirs
publics et à l'autorité en général donc
si on oblige on va raviver tous les
discours complotistes et je pense qu'ils
sont évidemment moins prégnant chez les
directeurs les médecins les infirmières
beaucoup plus chez les professionnels
peu fort mais je crois au contraire et
nous croyons qu'il faut essayer de
convaincre et on voit bien que le taux
de vaccination dans les établissements
pour personnes âgées par exemple il a
considérablement augmenté au début de la
campagne il était à peine de 20%
aujourd'hui on est à plus de 50 dans
certains établissements à près de 70 on
voit bien que la conviction
c'est aujourd'hui ce qui est le le plus
efficace rendre obligatoire ça irait à
l'encontre de l'objectif de la deuxième
salve de questions d'indiens sur le
groupe
ah bon alors mal perçu merci merci
présidente
bien sûr je j'adhère à tous les propos
qui ont été tenus
je voudrais soulever trois points de
notre commission tout au long de cette
crise qu vide et notamment au mois de
mars et avril autant que je m'en
souvienne nous avons auditionné beaucoup
de deux médecins d'experts et notamment
les fédérations que ce soit des aides à
domicile ou autre et cette notion de
glissements je parle notamment au niveau
des ehpad cette notion de glissements et
qui étaient déjà pointés du doigt ou au
mois de mai où nous expliquer qu'il
valait mieux avoir des relations
sociales ce qui paraît évident que
souvent les personnes se laissait aller
et que on était sur la nutrition sur
tout ce qui est matériel en oublie en
oubliant ce qui était humain tout ça
quand je m'en souvienne ça a été pointée
pratiquement au mois de mai c'est quand
même à teyran de voir qu'un an après on
est encore en train de se poser des
questions sur ce risque de glissement on
a beaucoup de familles moi je le vois
mais comme vous dans nos communes de
famille qui s'interroge vous l'avez très
bien soulever monsieur
aussi sur le fait qu'on a classé entre
guillemets le décès de la personne qu
vide alors que pour beaucoup c'était du
glissement il faut s'interroger sur les
décès dans les ehpad le nombre qui a été
relevé si cela relève aussi du coc vide
ou pas cette question et me semble-t-il
à ce que l'on doit se poser
et puis dans tous les acteurs
aujourd'hui qui interviennent pour la
perte d'autonomie ne faut pas oublier
les résidences autonomie sortie des
alizés da domicile des ehpad
mais moi j'ai bougé des résidences
autonomie sûrement départements des
associations aujourd'hui qui sont en en
désarroi parce que les familles ne
veulent plus
même dans une résidence autonomie les
familles ne veulent plus mettre leurs
parents et donc cette cette porte entre
l'ehpad et l'aide à domicile risque de
se fermer
puisqu'on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui comme
l'a très bien dit bernard jomier en
s'interroge sur les ehpad et on le voit
bien beaucoup beaucoup d pas de beaucoup
de familles ne veulent plus mettre leurs
parents en ehpad alors tout ça sans
pointer du doigt je pense qu'il faut
faire aussi ressortir tout ce qui a été
positif moi j'ai des cas de directeurs
d'ehpad de président de conseil
d'administration qui ont pris un peu de
largesses entre guillemets avec les
protocoles et ça a été bénéfique parce
qu'il ya les familles mais il ya aussi
tous les intervenants dans les ehpad
il ya aussi les associations on a fermé
les portes d'un seul coup à toutes ces
personnes et compte
j'ai noté quand on parle de droit de
visite au delà du droit de visite
il ya aussi des familles vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure monsieur qui se substitue
au manque de personnel et d'un seul coup
on leur a dit vous ne devez pu entrer
nous c'est interdit pour vous et ça ça a
été aussi ça a été très difficile très
difficile à vivre donc effectivement il
faut s'interroger aussi sur ces
protocoles très restrictif qui qui font
que comme à chaque fois on ouvre on peut
le comprendre le parapluie et peut-être
faire appel aussi à du bon sens je pense
qu'on est tous
parents enfants et vice et versa et
peut-être que remettre un peu de bon
sens dans tout ça ce serait pas
complètement absurde
merci daniel st merci je vous aime le
président donc moi je suis ou les jeux
est tracé quand même assez rapide
tout ce qui a été dit concernant
monsieur frémont etc et qui a perdu son
père dans des conditions très
douloureuse donc ce qu'a dit donc
bernard jomier la présidente
mais je suis bien sûr d'accord c'est
peut-être pas en changeant la loi mme
c'est un problème d'humanité
deuxièmement effectivement on n'a pas
ces personnages dans les ehpad de ça ce
qu'elle y alla miron c'est vrai depuis
très très longtemps puisque je me
rappelle delà de l'adaptation de la
société au vieillissement où on pensait
qu'à voir les crédits finalement il
n'avait pas en 2016 donc ce que ce qui
est demandé c'est ce qui est demandé à 1
c'est effectivement de doubler le père
des personnels soignants et ça on
demande depuis très longtemps et c'est
absolument indispensable bon j'espère
que ça va arriver alors moi en ce qui me
concerne
en ce qui concerne les restrictions en
ehpad donc moi je n'existe y fit alors
dans beaucoup d'endroits que je connais
les familles ont été associés dans la
prise de décision quant au directeur
parce que actuellement on est vacciné
donc ça commence à aller très bien mais
je voudrais vous rappeler qu'il ya un an
c'était une angoisse losc avait une
personne âgée qui avait commis tout un
personnel qui avait co vite il faut se
rappeler de ça on avait une angoisse que
toute la maison de plain l'ehpad soit
contaminée avec dd c'est catastrophique
je voudrais donner simplement un exemple
une dame est revenue de l'hôpital dans
mon ehpad dans un sens dans le secteur
où il ya des démences
sur 15 et bien tout le monde a été
contaminé donc notre angoisse c'était
que le personnel ne perpétue pas aux
étages et que les familles ne viennent
pas pour que toute la maison de retraite
les pac soit ceux contaminés donc alors
bien sûr la liberté du patient mais
aussi la liberté de ne pas avoir le qi
d'un bon donc moi je pense que dans la
majorité des cas par la très grande
majorité des cas ça a été fait non pas
pour préserver le directeur mais pour
préserver les pensionnaires et ça a été
fait aussi avec beaucoup de travail du
personnel
un gros travail de personnel pour
empêcher les glissements
voilà ce que je voulais ce que je
voulais dire donc je suis je justifie
absolument le pendant un certain temps
maintenant effectivement les gens sont
vaccinés mais justifie l'isolément
pendant pendant l'année totalement pour
ne pas avoir la totalité des
pensionnaires dont qui seraient
contaminés en ce qui concerne la
vaccination je termine là je voudrais
rappeler que la vaccination ne ne
supprime pas la contagion totalement
donc on peut penser aussi que même s'il
ya moins de charge virale au niveau du
gh2 du nez mais ça subrip bakos concert
complètement la contagion donc je pense
que les personnes même vacciné qui vont
à l'extérieur
eh bien elles doivent à mon avis rester
quelques jours isolé merci bien donc je
vous rappelle qu'à 11 heures nous
devrons terminé l'audition pour
l'édition suivante 4 pour s'opposer
d'alors il ya évidemment beaucoup de
choses qui ont été dites et je ne vais
pas revenir pour ma part sur le fait
qu'effectivement nous pensons laurence
cohen l'a fort bien dit et d'autres
collègues
qu'il y ait un manque criant de
personnel et dans les ehpad et dans les
hôpitaux et que donc forcément avec
toutes ces difficultés que nous
rencontrons quotidiennement et dans les
ans les hôpitaux et dans les ehpad et
bien les choses se sont mal se sont mal
déroulées il faut bien le dire
et puis je pense que le manque de
visibilité nationale il de l'état sur ce
qu'il fallait faire ou ne pas faire
ah évidemment brouiller les pistes
puisque ça a été dit et je l' ai vécu
dans mon département le pas de calais
nous avons été durement frappés nous
avons vécu des situations totalement
opposés d'une ville à l'autre et même
dans la dent dans une ville parfois
d'année pas d'un autre ou d'un hôpital
un autre hôpital
donc il y a eu évidemment toute la
latitude chacun chacun faisait un peu
comme ils le pouvaient dans son ehpad et
dans son hôpital et donc eh bien ça a
créé beaucoup de confusion
c'est évident que quand il n'y a pas de
directive nationale de la part de l'état
chacun fait comme il le veut ou comme il
le peut parce que je rappelle quand même
que nombre de personnels sont venus vous
nous voire agresser parfois par les
familles qui voulaient voir leurs
proches et c'est normal et légitime mais
en tous les cas le personnel a aussi
beaucoup souffert de cette situation et
et ça a été dit moi je me demande donc
j'attends beaucoup aussi de cette
audition on a même j'ai été interpellé
mais comme plusieurs de mes collègues
par des familles qui étaient dans une
détresse totale
par exemple sur des gens on a même été
confrontés parfois personnellement à ce
genre de situation à part des gens qui
allaient mourir qui sont morts un seul
j'ai été interpellé
y compris je ne suis pas croyante mais
par des familles musulmanes
parce qu'il existe quand la personne va
mourir
et bien de la toilette alors qu'on
savait que la personne était morte que
la membre de la famille une fille ou un
enfant voulait aller faire la toilette
de la maman 1 où il y avait les deux
parents qui étaient décédées et donc
qu'ils n'ont même pas pu procéder à
cette chose qui est pour eux quand même
il faut bien le dire quelque chose de
très important et donc même ce respect
là n'a pas été autorisé j'ai compris des
familles qui ont perdu des enfants en
situation de handicap à l'hôpital qui ne
sont parvenus et et qui n'ont même pas
pu assister leurs enfants dans leurs
derniers moments d'eau en a on a vécu
effectivement et les uns et les autres
et personne n'était humains et personne
ici n'est pour voit l'année pour cette
situation mais on l'a vécue parce qu'il
faut se rappeler que nous étions en en
pleine pandémie et que je le dis je le
redis le manque de visibilité visibilité
excusez-moi gouvernementale ne nous a
pas facilité la tâche
alors faut-il aujourd'hui légiférer ou
pas j'ai regardé la proposition du
président du groupe l'est républicain
bruno retailleau sur le droit de visite
dont cas parce que c'est ça finalement
aujourd'hui qui nous est posée faut-il
légiférer sur un droit de visite à
l'hôpital et dans les établissements
pour personnes âgées et handicapées
je vous avoue que la classe moment ma
décision à cet instant précis ma
décision
notre décision n'est toujours pas prise
parce que nous aimerions dire oui il
faut légiférer et il faut qu'il y ait
une loi mais est ce la solution
franchement voilà après c'est pas parce
que on le fait au pape on est plus ou
moins c'est parce que finalement on est
en train de regarder un peu les choses
puisque les restrictions ça a été dit
par plusieurs
un droit de visite ou les interdire
voilà c'est une de mes questions je vous
remercie
je mouillais personnel est présente dans
les nuits des interventions on voit bien
que ce matin on se pose beaucoup de
questions sur la no show non de
légiférer sol doit vite alors nos
intervenants ont des points de vue
différents même s'ils sont d'accord sur
le constat dont j'aurais voulu que de
nourrir et insisté sur l'accès de
questions fondamentales
c'est que en cas de en cas de textes de
loi qui encadre le droit visite
notamment dans les ehpad
quid de la responsabilité du directeur
d'établissement pour protéger la vie des
autres résidents c'est quand même la
question fondamentale et dans les
prothèses inversement où il n'ya pas de
texte de laubois sait comment peut être
mieux contrôlés l'opportunité la
proportionnalité des décisions
d'encadrement qui sont prises par les
directeurs d'établissement ça veut
peut-être pas ces mêmes parents heureux
questionnement sur une leçon de
certification peut-être des
établissements une question qui pète
rouse et puis une question peut être à
plus long terme on est bien vu que c'est
une crise entraînée voilà des
changements de comportement de la façon
de prendre en charge les passions les
résidents la façon d'accueillir les
familles
est ce que finalement dans l'avenir il
faut peut-être aussi par enfin peut-être
penser les aménagements les plantes
structure des établissements peut-être
pour permettre une meilleure capacité à
gérer cet îlot difficulté comme l
inverse
présentons jours à tous et à tout
d'abord j'aimerais remercier le
professeur martin weale alors que la
distinction entre les états les
établissements accueillant des personnes
âgées et les établissements de santé
je partage les propos du président mi
longs et concernant les moyens
et puis devrait représenter 80 des
roches sur à ce grave défaut d'humanité
notamment quand les patients sont
décédés
et est ce grave défaut d'humanité qui a
qui a conduit nos collègues à réfléchir
à une proposition de loi de trois
questions
dans les établissements de santé les
visites aujourd'hui sont encore très
restreinte mais ce qui est normal que
dans un même service les autorisations
visite sans parler de patients atteints
dès qu il soit dépendant de la décision
du médecin qui est présente un même
service quatre médecins et quatre
décisions différentes pour un même
patient qui est stable pour les familles
c'est incompréhensible leur droit de
visite est liée à la décision du médecin
qui est présente ce jour-là
là il ya une grande interrogation et
j'aurais voulu avoir votre avis sur ce
sujet la deuxième question qui me
taraude cms que une loi qui instaurerait
un droit de visite
résistera dans le cas d'une pandémie
majeure telle qu'on la connaît à une
autre loi d'urgence sanitaire est ce que
elle résisterait à des protocoles venant
de la direction générale de la santé
voilà ça c'est pour moi une vraie
interrogation et enfin peut-être une
dernière question est ce que dans une
telle loi il faudrait redéfinir la
compétence et c'est peut-être monsieur
marc dupont qui pourrait me répondre la
compétence du directeur d'établissement
en matière d'organisation des visiteurs
j'aurai plein de choses à dire mais je
vais m'arrêter là qu'on sait aujourd'hui
aussi beaucoup très bien pour conclure à
laurent blanc va merci madame
moi j'aimerais revenir quelques instants
sur les propos fait la réflexion qui lui
sur l'obligation de vaccination du
personnel médical
faut dire que à titre personnel le
citoyen que je suis bien sûr est
favorable à la vaccination mais que le
législateur que je suis défavorable à me
poser à nos concitoyens de se faire
vacciner sur le principe de liberté je
crois que chacun est libre de faire ce
qu'il veut que je crois que si on aime
poser au personnel médical faire
vacciner
cette décision quel espoir législatives
au par décret ne tiendrait pas quelques
secondes s'il y avait un recours devant
la cour constitutionnelle autre registre
hâtif
je pense que le juge se casseraient
cette décision au nom du principe de
d'inégalités par rapport à nos
concitoyens
et puis revenir par rapport aux propos
de monsieur frémont et je dirais que
j'ai trouvé ça son témoignage émouvant
et salué son courage alors lui dire
qu'un principe c'est vrai que les
acteurs n'aiment pas trop légiférer sur
l'émotion mais à titre personnel je
crois que j'aurais rejoint par beaucoup
je crois que la proposition que fait
notre président bruno retailleau c'est
de donner un message politique et je
crois qu'à un moment il faut que les
initiateurs aussi de temps en temps dans
un message politique un grand p par
rapport à ces familles qui ont été
touchés et je crois que ça sera à
l'honneur du sénat d'ailleurs cela très
bien alors pour répondre
madame même professeur par rapport à aux
questions de la vie vous quittez dans
deux minutes par rapport à questions qui
vous préoccupent sur fautif ou pas joly
dit d'une façon globale pour nom il faut
légiférer pour casser le statut ou pad
sur la question précise des visites
je ne me prononcerai pas mais en tout
état de cause s'il décide de suivre
l'avis du président otayo où tout cas sa
proposition il faut ce moment là que
si il y à un texte de long une
proposition de loi sur les visites
il faut s'appuyer sur la vie des
personnes âgées et des familles
actuellement du conseil de la vie
sociale et prendre du temps pour écouter
l'avis des résidents ça me paraît
absolument fondamental je vous prie de
m'excuser je dois vous quitter je vous
salue tous et toutes
merci beaucoup charvet et madame manawi
peut-être par rapport au poids sur
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants ça
existe déjà pour les baptise b notamment
donc il n'y a pas de difficultés c'est
s'est instaurée par la loi dans le code
de la santé publique pour la toilette
sénatrice évoqué le fait que la toilette
rituel ne peut pas il fait parler les
personnes de religion musulmane
effectivement c'est toujours le cas mais
c'est instaurer par décret c'est le
pouvoir réglementaire
donc concrètement la toilette mortuaire
en cas de mort par le cos vide n'est pas
possible sauf enfin elle est faite par
les professionnels de santé et par les
professionnels thanatologie n'aimez pas
la toilette rituel aujourd'hui elle est
interdite par décret donc bon on ne peut
que l'appliquer et effectivement dans
les débuts de delà de l'épidémie s'était
il y avait vraiment des situations qui
ont été très choquant moi j'ai vu des
cas où mais tout le monde était un peu
paralysés par la peur
fermez pas les yeux des morts à quelque
chose de très très choquant en disant ah
ben on peut plus y toucher une fois
qu'il est mort donc au même lui fermer
les yeux on se posait la question
donc voilà c'est effectivement cette
épidémie a entraîné des situations
particulièrement difficiles et on s'est
demandé pourquoi on pouvait faire la
toilette de quelqu'un qui était
hospitalisé parce qu'il était mort on
pouvait plus faire sa toilette
mais bon voilà les après sur le
différents des médecins effectivement
ces problématiques et c'est un
uniquement pour le droit de visite
c'est problématique quand vous demandez
des informations que le médecin vous
disiez le pronostic vital est engagé à
très court terme il vous fait très très
peur et puis le lendemain vous demandez
un look médecin il vous dit mais non ça
va aller tout va aller bien et ça c'est
quelque chose que je vois très
régulièrement d'expertisé des familles
qui viennent dire on nous a donné des
informations très contradictoires d'un
jour un jour alors une fois que les deux
médecins se parlent plus communiquent
plus entre eux pour savoir quelles
informations ils donnent aux familles
effectivement et c'est vrai pour le
droit de visite comme pour tout le reste
c'est quand même très violent de devenir
à l'hôpital et de se voir refuser un
droit de visite un jour et puis le
lendemain de se le voir autoriser par un
autre médecin
je suis bien d'accord avec vous la
difficulté c'est que tout ça ça me sens
à mon avis ça se règle pas par par la
loi mais par de l'appréciation au cas
par cas et de l'humanité voilà un
monsieur dupont faut soit tas de choses
sur l'épaule quand j'ai été un peu
évoqué d'ailleurs soit avec mort tué
l'un je complète soit avec mortuaires
aux musulmanes jeu complet clair et ce
que disait madame anna oui ou non
seulement le décret de prévoir mais même
les autorités religieuses on a une
lettre un courrier de la mosquée de
paris dès le mois de mars 2020 qui dit
on à nous qui avons plus de toilettes
rituel par les autorités religieuses
c'est un panier pour autant que les que
les personnes meilleur goal des moules
pas individuellement personnellement
sous préfet mondial de faire des
toilettes
en tout cas même sur ce problème les
autres dirigeants ont été extrêmement
[Musique]
oui encore pris position
l'assurance chaussée pour la question
reportant sur le rôle du directeur c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui le droit de visite
c'est le directeur qui prend des
décisions moi qui fixe la politique de
l'étape de l'établissement et ensuite
les décisions sont prises sur avis
médical
enfin le directeur intervient très peu
auraient été les intervient lorsqu'il ya
un litige lorsqu'il ya un conflit et
c'est bien au niveau de l'équipe alors
l'équipe il si important qu'il soit
soudées effectivement qu'il ya des
décisions cohérentes au sein de l'équipe
mais ça me semble un bon principe qu'il
ya un directeur qui peut des décisions
lorsqu'il faut trancher vraiment sûr
avec un avis médical soignant très très
bien documenté sachant que ces choses
sont différentes cambre dans une
maternité dans une descente au natif par
exemple c'est bien normal que ce soit au
niveau local cas par cas au niveau de
l'unité que les choses se passent c'est
pas ce moment en fait le fait qu'ils
aient aussi un double niveau ça permet
aussi d'avoir un recours tout à l'heure
on a parlé du recours c'est parfois
certains ont contesté le fait qu'ils
puissent pas faire recours
le fait que le directeur soit en 2d
niveau ça permet lorsque l'équipe
médicale a pris une décision d'avoir un
mieux pour pouvoir dire écoutez j'ai
encore on considère la situation
quelque chose à acheter
le premier pour rebondir sur la notion
glissement je pense que c'est un thème
important d'avoir en tête que n'y a pas
d'un côté des personnes qui seraient
porteuses d'une douce d'un cyborg de
sérieux sanitaire qui aurait conscience
des dangers qu'ils protègeraient et
l'autre côté de dangereuses idéaliste
libertaire humaniste ce qu on a
redécouvert à ce que beaucoup de
gériatres nous en dit pendant la crise
et qu' il y avait ce danger de
contamination de contracter le virus ou
de le transmettre mais il y avait aussi
tous les risques gériatrique habituelles
liées à l'interruption des activités des
visites d'un certain nombre de
thérapeutique la dénutrition métro
cognitif la dépression la perte
d'autonomie fonctionnelle la sarcopénie
est donc en permanence retrouver même
face à un risque majeur la conscience de
ces risques
outre risque qui reste nécessite des
arbitrages déséquilibres des balances
entre des préjudices différents et c'est
très difficile de le faire quand on line
tétanisés par la peur mais quand il
s'agit de récupérer très vite la
capacité de d'avoir ses arbitrages
le deuxième point c'est effectivement
mon avis le jeu je souscris à l'idée que
la question de l'accompagnement des
mourants et 2d d hommage rendu au défunt
il ya une question spécifique
il ya eu ce décret sur la mise en bière
immédiate qui a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre on a quand même mis huit mois
avant qu'une décision du conseil d'état
pour la critiquer alors évidemment au
début de crise quand on sait pas
quand on maîtrise pas les modalités de
contamination et qu'on se dit est-ce que
c'est comparable à ivo labbé ont réagi
au maximum mais c'est peut-être que la
difficulté que huit mois là d'ssus les
problématiques alors quand en plus on a
eu assez vite des éléments montrant qu
il y avait des différences majeures
selon les pays y compris selon les pour
les différents toilette mortuaire
soignantes et et rituels et donc la
question c'est un peu comment on évite
l'arbitraire danser dans ces cas là que
ce soit pour autoriser les visites ou
pour mettre en place ce type de règles
et comment on n a peut-être une prudence
dans l'éduction d'une norme parce que
mise en bière immédiate a été appliquée
parfois de manière très différente
immédiate a pas été entendue toujours de
la même façon et a parfois été appliquée
possiblement avec une trop extrême
rigueur alors qu'à d'autres endroits on
a pu avoir un peu plus de souplesse
donc le pour moi la question majeure là
sur ce point c'est comment on peut
éviter l'arbitraire et retrouver une
capacité de discernement même en
situation très anxiogène merci beaucoup
à tout ce qu'on vous serez coûté et tous
vos appareils sont assez intéressants
effectivement je vous rejoins on a parlé
du droit au respect de la dignité du
patient qui est donc bafoué depuis plus
d'un an
il ya aussi la question du droit à la
liberté de conscience et de religion
et avant même les protocoles funéraire
la question de l'accès aux derniers
sacrements pour toutes les religions
avec des aumôniers qui sont restés
bloqués pour des services et qu'il leur
reste toujours avec évidemment des
situations très variables d'un
établissement à l'autre
mais voilà il ya des personnes qui
partent aujourd'hui dénuée d d'un
sacrement alors qu'elle elle réclame
aussi
enfin je vois très concrètement vous
faire part de mon ressenti et deux des
nombreux témoignages qu'on reçoit ce
ressenti face à l'arbitraire médicale
quand on se retrouve devant une porte
fermée qui ne s'ouvrent pas qu'on a
aucun texte sur lequel se fonde et il
n'y a aucune recommandation officielle
sur le sujet et donc je pense que à
défaut d'une circulaire du ministre qui
n'a n'a pas l'air de se décider à agir
et ce serait vraiment tout à l'honneur
de
du sénat d'inscrire ce droit dans la loi
et je pense que ce serait d'une grande
aide pour toutes les victimes de ces
situations il y en a beaucoup parlé du
contexte spécifique à la pandémie
mais on a bien peur que ce genre de
comportement ne sont pas tendres le les
habitudes des de certaines équipes
encore une façon sans généraliser mais
tout simplement se débarrasser des
familles c'est parfois créer des
pratiques et souligné qu' on connaît
deux de très graves dérives éthiques
anthropologique depuis maintenant plus
d'un an donc le ministre sentez le 16
février dernier affirme devant
l'assemblée des visites doivent être
autorisées pour tous ses atouts une
hospitalisation mais rien n'est fait
concrètement pour que ce droit de visite
soit appliquée donc je pense que ce
serait tout à l'honneur du sénat de
reconnaître ce droit fondamental des
passions
[Musique]